this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck and
minimalists hello simpletons welcome to
the minimalist podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name is Joshua fields
Milburn and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists lately
we've been thinking a lot about what
minimalism will look like after this
moment of uncertainty is there going to
be a movement of neo minimalism that
forms in the wake of this reset that's
what we're going to explore today what
is essential what is excess what's a
meaningful life many of the questions
are the same but are the answers
different and many new questions are
forming well yesterday's answers help us
or do we need to find new answers Ryan I
was listening to our friend Rob Bell his
podcast he was talking about this moment
as the great unmasking which I thought
was a great metaphor because initially
because we're all wearing masks right
now we're well and many of us are a
podcast Sean was just up in Montana and
he said it was basically business as
usual so it depends it's very region
specific right now yeah right and so I
wore a mask in here to get through the
lobby and the elevators and the elevator
in my apartment building but I was I
finished writing yet this was just
yesterday actually I finished writing in
the morning and actually finished it by
the afternoon working on this new book
love people use things and the third
draft is coming along beautifully and I
had a good productive day I felt great
and I walked out into my neighborhood I
was walking around and this was it was
like a week earlier everything was
boarded up and there were protests and
riots but yesterday everything was open
and there was a sense of normalcy not
back to normal but places were packed I
mean and some of them they seemed
dangerously packed and I'm wondering
like the pendulums can swing too far
right and that's what we need to be
careful of and and so we're gonna be
asking a lot of questions they obviously
answering some questions as well I think
in many ways this has been the most
difficult year
of our lifetimes our collective
lifetimes yeah and it's only June I know
right half of the year isn't even over
yeah now for me it's not the most
difficult year of my life 2019 was
actually the most difficult year of my
life and I've seen 20/20 I remember at
the beginning of the year a lot of
people were using the sort of cheesy
admittedly cheesy metaphor 20/20 vision
oh yeah did anyone see this coming no
did they see a virus sweeping the globe
did they see a nation at unrest because
of racism and and protests and looting
and riots which we talked about a lot on
last week's episode with TK Coleman so
we're not going to get back into that
anymore
but I don't think we saw any of this
coming but we also saw the possibility
we've predicted it in films and and we
know that things can always go off the
rails at a moment's notice and so we
started asking the more essential
questions again I know for me 2019 was
the most difficult year but 2020 in many
ways has been a year of of healing for
me personally and I'm wondering that
once we get on the other side of this is
it a year of healing for us as a
community as a state as a city as a
nation as a as a world and if so did it
take this sort of unmasking or or did it
take exposing our wounds so to speak to
allow us to begin to heal and I'm
noticing people asking a lot of these
questions that you and I have really
been grappling with over the last decade
since we started the minimalists and I
started with some of those questions at
the top of this what is essential and so
we're gonna talk about that today we've
got some questions before we do I want
to just explain why this episode is
coming out a day late it's actually the
first time we've ever done this but we
had an episode that was supposed to come
out today mm-hmm the you and I just
didn't feel good about and I think this
is a a testament to how much our world
has changed in just the last 10 days 10
days ago we were
an episode with Dave Rubin someone who I
agree with 60 to 80 percent of the time
about a lot of things some people call
him left-wing some people call him
right-wing some people call him Center I
don't know what what does he call
himself what does he identify as he says
he's a classical liberal classical
liberal yeah and so that could mean a
bunch of things as well and so we had a
really good conversation with him that
went off the rails a few times and it in
fact I emailed him yesterday he and I
are supposed to talk on the phone later
today I believe the conversation
recorded just felt so outmoded so
out-of-date just ten days later now he
said some things that you and I had
disagreed with him about we pushed back
on yeah given the current circumstances
I wish we would have pushed back a
little bit harder yeah so what I'd like
to do instead of publishing that episode
cuz I don't feel good about editing it
with especially without his permission
yeah dude I mean yeah we're not gonna
censor him right especially the irony of
that is it's an episode about free
speech right so we recorded this episode
about free speech but we are postponing
that we're gonna try to get him back in
here
to have a more evergreen conversation
about free speech oh so we're not gonna
publish that one at all I mean maybe at
some point we could publish it on
patreon as a as an example of like
failed conversations and and and the
lessons that we learn we'd have to I
think add maybe even a commentary in
between the the questions and and and
the discussion points and I think we we
can do that but you and I both talked
about it and we just didn't feel good
enough to publish it as it was right now
so I'm gonna talk to Dave see if we can
get him back in here or maybe we end up
editing the episode and doing something
with it with his permission obviously
but I just don't feel good about it the
way that it is so we're in here today
talking about neo minimalism something
that I think will be appropriate for
today but I think the questions we
answer today will be appropriate for
years to come because these are
questions that many of us are gonna be
dealing with again and again as we reach
these new milestones in life and we
start questioning what is essential I
think these questions are really
important it surprised me how because
like you know
years of talking about minimalism I
don't know why this surprised me you
know I kind of felt like we've covered
it all you know like we've pretty much
covered well and then the pandemic
happens and I was just surprised I like
oh wow like here's this old answer mmm
that is coming up for these new problems
so yeah the neo minimalism or the new
minimalism you could say yeah it
certainly is going to it's going to
address what we're going through right
now with the pandemic and what debt and
yeah I just it's plenty up with my
sister God love her she actually you
know what I don't want to talk about her
her personal stuff let's just say that
she got into debt right before the
pandemic and I really tried to talk her
out of it right and now she is um you
know she's got to worry about that now I
mean luckily she's back at work and
everything's okay uh-huh
but it's just like this stress that she
was like oh Ryan like she's like god I
should have you know maybe I should have
paid attention to more to what you were
saying you know I talked to Dave Ramsey
about this we did a quarantine
conversation with Dave Ramsey for our
patreon folks and it was just this 15
minute conversation I had with him but I
started off by saying how many years
have you been telling people they need a
budget and now they're finally figuring
it out during these hard times and we're
dealing with this 3-legged crisis right
now Ryan there-there is of course the
virus which is still out there
and there is the financial crisis one
might even say depression it's certainly
a reset going to be a recession so we
know the economy is bounce back so
quickly well as far as well stock market
goes yeah that's not the economy in a
401 K s yeah I guess I'm just surprised
at that that is an indicator of the
economy
I heard crystal ball on the hill called
the stock market a graph of rich
people's feelings but yeah I well I mean
we've got you know an IRA and some
savings and stuff so I haven't been
keeping too close of an eye on it
because it's like kind of depressing
really but the fact that it is an
indicator of the economy it is an
indicator of what's going on and the
fact that that indicator is
up as much as it is over the past like
two months actually kind of tells me
something's wrong right well again this
is so most people don't participate in
the stock market is it twenty percent of
people it's less than twenty percent of
people participate in the stock no we're
talking index funds or we're talking
individual stocks right right now most
people you know so fidelity fidelity did
this thing about the people whose
accounts perform the best this is a
really fascinating study that they did
where the peep were their customers who
didn't who forgot they had a fidelity
account no because it's set it and
forget it like that is the best
investment advice unless you're a day
trader which you spend you know all day
trading full-time job right is that most
so okay so 401ks and IRAs and those
things those are that's money in stock
whether it's mutual funds or whether
it's index funds correct so what I'm
hearing you say is that less than 20
percent have mutual funds index funds
any stocks of any source so that eighty
percent of people are not are basically
not putting their money away in any kind
of stock for retirement that's correct
Wow yeah and so those numbers change
quite a bit and so you may have a you
may have a 401k account that you
contributed to once but if you don't
contribute to irregularly then you
wouldn't be considered participant oh
okay I see yeah so so the set it and
forget it folks are not there in that 80
percent well yeah so it depends on how
they would measure it but but yes if if
you just put 5,000 dollars into an
account one time then they probably
aren't going to count you for that okay
pretty regularly
yeah on a monthly or annual basis then
you're gonna be part of that but the
truth is that most people don't
contribute to a retirement account and
although you certainly should even a
person who makes a minimum wage this is
what was staggering to me when I learned
when I was very young if you contribute
23 dollars a week from the time you're
18 I believe it is or maybe it's 21 I
have this new stat in our in our next
book actually love people use things and
there's a whole chapter in about our
relationship with money in there
and the thing is anyone can become a
millionaire by the time they retire by
contributing $23 a week roughly up until
65 yeah 59 and a half I think it is but
you know I'd have to look at the math
it's all it's all there in the book in
fact it's so staggering that the the
editor was like is this math true well
she was like she she was like we have
two editors but the big out she's young
and she was like is this true III really
what I was learning and she was like oh
I think I should be putting more money
in stock market she's so young like now
is the best time to actually contribute
a few if you're young if you're old like
me and Ryan you have to contribute more
money right or could you be twenty three
thousand dollars a week we're gonna have
to dock your pay twenty three thousand a
week okay anyway we have a lot of
questions today I know we've been
monitoring on a bit before we get into
it Ryan there was one other thing that I
wanted to talk about but now it has it
has floated off into the ether maybe
it'll come back to me but until it does
so he take a note on the back your paper
was it there
oh the oh we were talking about the the
three yes the three crises that we have
going on right now
oh yes so we have the pandemic the virus
yeah we have the financial crisis yes
and now we have this crisis of
inequality then has been there for a
long time but it's really coming up to
the forefront whether it's racial
inequality and also financial inequality
which those things are inextricably tied
together as well you can go back to last
week's race relations episode to hear us
talk about that in detail but what I'm
saying is we have three crises right now
but this episode is about crises in
general and what happens after the
crises and here's the thing the one
thing I'm certain of is other crises are
going to happen whether it's a
large-scale crises crisis like like the
pandemic or you lose your job that's an
individual crisis right you you have a
health crisis like I had last year
that's a crisis and coming out of the
crisis requires course correction and it
requires healing and those are the
things that I really wanted to talk
about today yeah it's it is like it's
just the perfect storm
right now what you piece of me is kind
of like scared of because you know
there's a lot of unknowns I mean I just
saw a poll recently it's like over 80
percent of people polled will say that
that America is out of control right now
and it's scary when the same token I'm
kind of glad we're taking a poll though
know these people I always wondered that
too Jordan have you taken I'm taking a
poll right now Jordan have you taken a
poll
have you ever taking a poll Oh have you
taken a poll so I'm guessing according
to my polling zero people have been
polled Ryan well you know I know that
they do a lot of polling data online and
they will they target on Facebook people
to poll so like I mean I don't know if
it's in person or what pullets from I
forget the news channel that I saw this
on but yeah all this to say is it yes I
feel like we're a bit out of control
right now but I am I am grateful that
this is going to lead to something
better I really do feel that you know
it's fascinating about that I agree with
you were out of control but you and I
also a decade ago recognized that we
meaning you and I and also our our
society writ large was out of control
yeah the the sort of post 2008 the 2008
crash led to this post 2008 thinking a a
sort of neo minimalism at the time or or
minimalism really blossoming online and
now I think over the last decade we face
new problems we have new distractions
social media is this whole new thing we
were facing new decadence and luxury in
ways that are unimaginable and that
that's for even for your average person
the richest king in the world fifty
years ago didn't have access to a
smartphone or the questionable toilet
right well years ago I hope they did
okay five hundred years ago for sure
yeah that there were yeah more issue so
many of the these things that we take
for granted are luxuries and there's
nothing wrong with a flushable toilet
right no no I recommend having one I
have to do you're such a fraud I know
right
and and so I I do want to question the
things that we use
and the things we feel like we need
versus the things that add value so
let's get into those questions right now
do it
Christina and Sacramento has a question
for us I had a question about adding
things to your wish list on amazon.com
so I was doing really well for a month I
wasn't buying anything I wasn't
introducing anything new to my house but
then I started to me you know just
cleaning supplies or replacement items
of things that I really really liked and
I added them to my wish list to watch I
got decreases if I was going to make a
saving so I would add a ton of stuff to
my wish list and then I would I'm
finding myself purchasing a lot of those
items because they're if there's a
notification that they're on sale or
that the price is decreased since I
added it to my wish list and I cannot
stop looking at my I cannot I'm
obsessively looking at my wish list and
adding things to my cart and it's so
easy just to press the place order
button and it's getting a little bit out
of hand and I could really just use a
refresher right so for those of us who
purged and really winter our stuff and
with on a really good track and paid off
our credit card debt I'm at a loss now
and I just I just need a little bit of a
tip or advice on how to get back on
track Christina I've got a real simple
vise for Christina get rid of your
Amazon account mmm
you don't have to keep it out of your
life but she is she has an issue right
now with with the wish list with Amazon
with spending too much time in there
we're spending too much money with
hoarding with what not with wording but
with starting a hoard yeah if if it's
that much of a crisis right now which it
sounds like it's bordering on get rid of
your Amazon for a month or two you know
what's fascinating about this ryan is
this this time of you stay at home I
think has really exacerbated online
shopping in a way because we've taken
away the the retail shopping yeah and so
if you I totally agree with you out the
first thing I would do is get rid of
Amazon for 30 days or bare minimum get
rid of Amazon Prime yeah because you
want to enter
some new friction into the process or
delete your wish list but you've got to
change your state somehow Christina and
yeah I totally do something for 30 days
to change your state and then maybe
revisit it but you know another piece of
advice is do not give out information if
you don't have to when you when you're
liking things on facebook when you are
adding things to your wish list I mean
even in your search browser I mean they
are collecting so much data so they can
mark it to you because Christina they
know that if they pull the right levers
they can make you do exactly what you're
doing for sure
I mean I in it's it's pretty good at
detecting what you're looking at I mean
Shawn and I were just talking about this
beforehand I was on LA Times looking up
an article about well I was on different
website looking at j.crew going out of
business like there are or not but I'm
sorry filing bankruptcy is not going out
of business
although and then the next day I get an
advertisement for like j.crew jeans on
LA Times because you know it populates
in their sidebar or whatever and so it's
making connections not even to the
things I'm looking at shopping about but
even the things I'm reading about yes
it's it's popping up and so Ryan you you
really hit the nail on the head here if
online shopping is your problem you want
to add some friction into the mix I do
this right now so I don't buy cleaning
supplies online because I think there's
a lot of wasted and and the the shipping
of that so I will intentionally add
friction to the process I spend more
time I'll go to a Target or somewhere
else and buy the cleaning supplies I
need however I also realize I need fewer
cleaning supplies and we actually think
right you need one sort of cleaning
thing that will it will the thing that
cleans your sink will also clean your
toilet will also clean your shower will
also clean your floor's honestly and so
to use castle soap now use our castile
so know the Meyer stuff although we had
someone recommend the the what is that
dr. Bronner's on the the politics
episode recently with Kim Iverson we had
we had a caller Cory thing yeah you can
wash your pants with that as well and so
yeah I think one thing that covers
everything makes the shopping simpler
but you don't want to make it easy
so it can be simple you can reduce the
number of things you buy but you can
also add friction into the into the
process I don't I don't buy groceries
that I have them delivered because I
prefer to be very intentional about
going out and buying only the things I
need and by the way whenever I go to the
store I buy only the things that are on
my list if I forgot to put on the list I
force myself to leave the store without
it I add some additional inconvenience
into my life not because I like
inconvenience because I hate impulse
really what you're talking about is
setting boundaries for yourself and
right now Christina doesn't have many
boundaries so Christina whatever
boundaries work for you you got to
implement those in your life yeah I'm
gonna recommend one last thing since
Ryan mentions boundaries you need some
rules for yourself now Ryan and I have a
minimalist rule book it's called sixteen
rules for living with less you can
download that for free from our website
on the resources page the minimalists
com /resources Christina I recommend you
read that and those rules are adjustable
to your life to your family and to your
preferences and so you'll find that
maybe the just in case roar the just for
win rule or the seasonality rule apply
to you or maybe you need to tweak them a
little bit so they apply to your life
and also Christina since you are in
Sacramento we've got a tour stop coming
up in Sacramento TK Coleman's gonna be
with us there we got a bunch of tour
stops coming up actually you can find
them over the minimalists comm slash
tour Christina I'd love to give you a
couple tickets to our Sacramento event
if you head on over to that web page for
anyone else who's listening to this you
can find the city nearest you if you
don't see your city you can sign up for
the email list there we'll notify you
when we were coming to a nearby city
Veronica in Salt Lake City has a
question for us how do you guys feel
towards emergency items such as a
72-hour kit and what other things do you
have for emergency type situations
now Ryan since we were just talking to
Christina about the minimalist rulebook
I might as well mention a few more rules
for Veronica
here so there are two rules in there in
particular I think that will work really
well because I think we're asking this
question differently now right she's
asking about emergency items well we
actually have an emergency item rule
it's different from the just incase rule
it's different from the just for win
rule
is a separate rule for like I have a
first-aid kit right that's an emergency
item when we lived in Montana I had like
a blanket in the trunk and yeah and a
shovel and some bleach and several body
bags just for when just for emergencies
yes so we have an emergency item rule
but here's the thing and I've had
several people ask this question
differently from how Veronica's
Veronica's asking it but many people
right now during a time like this where
it feels like an emergency and for many
people it is a sort of pseudo emergency
right I haven't needed any new emergency
items yeah it is pandemic I got rid of a
couple emergency items moving from
Montana to California right because yeah
like you don't need a wool blanket you
know or a tire chain I don't even have a
wool blanket I had the the emergency
blankets yeah tire chains exactly
exactly and so I'm gonna recommend that
rule but there's one other rule is well
that has served me well it's called the
willing to walk rule in my life I'm I
set my life up and by the way I think
everyone has this to a certain extent I
think this my threshold is lower it's
the willingness to walk away from
anything that could be the minimalists
it could be my marriage it could be
friendships it could be any physical
item for sure I'm willing to walk away
from the city in which I live being
willing to walk away means that I'm
intentionally staying in the thing
because it best serves me and I best
serve it and if if we're not willing to
walk away then that means we are only
willing to sort of placate and that's
not a place of contentment or joy that
that's actually a recipe for misery stew
and some some real discontent and and
and so having a willingness to walk away
the rule in that rule book I think will
help you out as well because if you feel
right now like you need to bring more
emergency items into your life I think
you really want to question those things
you have and right now I agree with you
I've actually walked away from more
things during this time I've donated a
few more things during this time we've
even been encouraging people who are on
our
next message lists to send us emojis of
the most recent thing they've declutter
in Ryan people have gotten so so
creative yeah of course physical items
their you know someone will send us a
emoji of an umbrella or a lot of peaches
have been D [ __ ] peaches and
eggplants anyway people have been but
also like smoking habits have been
decluttered during this time and so
different habits people were
decluttering by the way if you want to
send us an emoji emoji it's just nine
thirty seven two oh two four six five
four those taxes go to both of our
phones yes no the one thing I'll add
here is Veronica you got to figure out
what's appropriate for your life too
because living in California for example
especially in Los Angeles we get a lot
of earthquakes so Mariah and I have
talked about having like a generator to
to power things in case there's like a
major disaster especially after watching
what was uh about the blackout the
documentary I figured what it was called
zero dark thirty it is zero though it is
zero days zero zero hour I think is zero
days Oh guys you're this but after
watching that I'm like oh wow like we
actually do need to plan for an outage
like it's going to happen and cuz it
with how fragile the the grid is
especially in LA with earthquakes and
there's a whole other things that that
that documentary goes into however I
don't have room for a generator right so
guess what I didn't get a generator but
if Mariah and I had a house and I had
the appropriate space for it I would
totally get that so Veronica again yes
have some emergency items but make sure
that you get only what's appropriate for
your life right and that will change
depending on a whole bunch of different
circumstances I think the the rule in
the rule book will help you identify
what those circumstances are Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer your text messages text your
questions or comments to nine thirty
seven to zero two four six five four yes
indeed as I said those texts go to both
of our phones and we do respond to as
many people as we can now during the
lightning round this will Ryan and I do
our best to answer every question with
just a short shareable less than 140
character response and we put the text
of these minimal Maxim's in the show
notes so you can copy and share our pit
the answers on social media if you
like and by the way you can find all of
our minimal Maxim's in one place now
minimal Maxim's com we have a question
from our old friend Mike Brewer Brewer
what a good dude
has your definition of the word
essential changed also how have your
perspectives on the word essential
changed
I'd like that he made these as two
separate questions because my definition
of essential hasn't changed I'll give
you a pithy answer on that one Mike if
it feels like too much it's too much and
and that's basically my definition of
essential now in that minimalist
rulebook that we've talked about a
couple times now we all we have another
rule in there it's called the no junk
rule and Ryan and I do a really good job
of delineating between essential items
non-essential items and junk items and
so your second question Mike is how also
how have your perspectives on the word
essential changed well really I what is
essential to me really helps me live
right but but I think it's different
from that which is non-essential but
increases or augments my experience of
life yeah Ryan and I you and I are
really for non essentials but we're not
for junk yeah and too many people
conflate the non essentials and the junk
so I know you've got something pithy for
us yeah for sure before I even read my
pit the answer here when I think about
essential items like that's what I take
when I go camping it's like just what I
need
but at home I'm not going to just live
with only the things that I must have
with only the essential that's what my
definition is so yeah my pithy answer is
this you'll survive living with what's
with what's essential but you'll thrive
living with what adds value so just to
your point we do need some non-essential
things in our life because if you live
with only the essential you're you're
living in deprivation I think of a monk
who eats they have their robes I mean
they got rid of their hair because they
don't need that's not a central so they
are but they are depriving themselves
intentionally because that's the
lifestyle they choose which is great but
that is not
we're advocating everyone do we're
advocating that people have in their
life what adds value what can what can
truly help them thrive not just survive
I just interviewed urban McManus for our
next film lessons now and he had this
great line that he said I think too many
people confuse minimalism with
utilitarianism right but I think that
beauty is essential yeah and I I love
that about about his distinction there
because he doesn't want just items that
only serve a purpose he wants beauty in
our everyday life through artwork and
creativity and also just through
aesthetics that is an essential part of
life that that nature is beautiful and I
think that's essential and I want to
bring that into my living space to work
space whatever I want to strip it down
so that we have the essentials in the
sense that when we get down to the
essentials it begins to expose the
beauty but I want to remove all the junk
I think that actually adds to the beauty
as well it's interesting though there's
such a fine line that I think we do when
we're thinking about what's essential
and what's non-essential and what's junk
and I've seen this on up and watching
orders talk about motivation like like
after watching hoarders I'm like oh
Mariah we need to get rid of like 50% of
our stuff because it like it makes me so
paranoid because I feel sorry for like
all these things that people are holding
on to right but they get to the line
that they're writing is you know one one
example is there's a woman who she goes
out and she'd trash dives and then she
sells stuff on eBay every time they
tried to get rid of something she's like
well you're gonna need to pay me $20 if
you want me to get rid of it because
that's what that's worth and in her mind
all of this stuff is essential because
it's worth money so it's just it's
something that it's a slippery slope
what our what our definition of
essential is right and so so for us we
both recognize that what she saw but is
not essential because it's not necessary
for her to live she's conflating the
non-essentials with the junk almost all
of those things are junk she's thinking
it's something that's adding value to
her life the non essentials that are
valuable as a potential to add value
right yeah everything has the potential
add value that's not good enough to hold
on to it yeah oh that's something pithy
I don't know if you you can clean that
up and tweet it Shawn
but uh oh right before we get into our
listener tips and our added value
segment say Ryan you are gonna love the
added value today I shared it with Sean
yesterday and now I've just really been
enjoying it but anyway before we get
into that we got a bunch more surprise
questions this week like what new home
workplace and digital minimalism trends
will we see in the near future in times
of isolation do new parameters need to
be set for what we hold on to is poverty
the new minimalism how do we maximize
ooh actually that that's a 14 slipper
how do we minimize bad relationships
that'll be maximized good relationships
is what I would say how do we minimize
bad relationships during a pandemic also
do the minimalist really want j.crew and
JCPenney to go out of business there was
some controversy around this on our last
maximum episode and so I want to talk
more about that the shorter answer is
yes but there's some nuance there I post
we've got a million more questions about
what minimalism might look like soon and
if you want to hear all that check out
this week's maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast it's a
completely separate weekly podcast and
it's just a couple bucks and it's the
most honest way for the minimalist to
earn an income because we don't believe
in advertisements you know we think
advertisement sucks so we make money
only if you find value in and support
what we create
head on over to the minimalists com a
slash support to subscribe and get your
personal links so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app Ryan what else you got for us this
week here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners check them
out this is Kathy from Illinois I have a
comment for Susan who had a baby in the
NICU I have also had a child who was in
the NICU and she's not 20 years old what
I did was I have two children
each child got one Apple box go to the
grocery store at the produce manager for
an Apple box it has a top and the lid
and you put what you want to keep in
that Apple box baby clothes I have a
quilt that was made by a dear friend and
as the years go by you only get the one
Apple box per child my children they're
not 22 and 20 and I've opened that box
and they've looked in there and none of
that means anything to either of them
but it means a lot to me
my name is Courtney and I'm from Houston
I just recently started listening to
your podcast and they're really bringing
a lot of value to my life and helping me
realize how much of a consumer I am I
actually just got done listening your
consumerism podcast and one tip that I
had was I found rocksbox
it's a subscription that kind of lets
you rent jewelry so it still satisfies
my consumer need where I want to
purchase the new and hip fashion but I
wear the jewelry for as long as I want
and then I send it back for someone else
to use and get value out of and it's
only like ten dollars a month so there's
other subscriptions out there similar
that I found are kind of awesome that
you can rent your clothing and jewelry
through all right Joe for this week's
added value man I tweeted this Ryan it's
that feeling when you stumble into
something special that's what I felt
when I happened upon Ken Yates's music
last week his new album it's called
quiet stalkers and it is a quiet
masterpiece he's a singer-songwriter and
it's weird it's the the music is is both
winsome and and and muscular like the
songwriting is like really muscular in
his very American which is ironic busy
because he's from London Ontario Canada
that's like America part 2 yeah London
especially you know I've been there
before we did a tour stop there and it's
very London is like might as well be a
city in Ohio right right and but it
feels very Midwestern there is a city in
Ohio called London
but like the one de non-tariff feels
very much like a a like this this
Midwestern media medium-sized city in a
way anyway this album quiet talkers is
it's like the perfect Drive music like
summertime drive through cornfields or
or the desert or like it's just it's
it's quiet but it's there's a song in
fact I want to put a link to the this
video because the video itself is like
it's a perfect song and a perfect video
together and they just complement each
other so well the the song is called two
wrongs it's about how two wrongs make us
right and some of the lyrics from this
thing Ryan I'll read you a few or he
says I'm too shaky to lean on I'm too
tired to be strong I'm too old to start
again and too young to believe it and
good yeah they're like I said there's
just this muscularity to it the the
music is so it's a fine example of the
power of restraint and the beauty of
concision and he's a young guy with an
old soul and the lyrics and the music go
together really really well so check out
Kevin Yates's album quiet talkers it's
almost like you know Jeffrey Foucault
it's like his music mixed with a little
Paul Simon in a way and then there's
something else that's unnameable and
utterly unique about his music so
definitely check it out ken Yates quiet
talkers is the new album check out the
video we'll put a link to it in the show
notes as well for two wrongs and real
quick for right here right now here's
one thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist Ryan we only do this once
or twice a year in fact I don't think we
did it at all last year so it's probably
been a year a year and a half since
we've asked this and because I hate when
people at every single episode make sure
you rate and review us all I can
subscribe right you're never gonna hear
me say like and subscribe ever and
you're not gonna hear us every episode
saying make sure you leave us a review
on Apple podcast I'm gonna ask you one
time I'm gonna ask you right now
my birthday is coming up I'm gonna be 39
this month on June 29th you might as
well be 50
so I'm thinking for my birthday if you'd
be willing now most of you aren't going
to you're just going to skip past this
part and that's really unfortunate
because it helps us spread this message
of living with less if you'd be willing
I would be very grateful it's one of the
best ways you can support this podcast
especially if you're not a patreon
supporter one of the best ways you can
support this podcast if you were to go
over to Apple podcast even if you don't
listen to this this podcast on Apple
podcast go over there and leave us a
review not just the stars but you write
something up what what do you believe
what about the podcast if you hate us
why have you been listening this long
that's fine you can say you hate us on
there I'm not asking you for a five-star
review you leave whatever review you
want but it would mean a lot to us
because it helps us spread the message
of living with less so we asked this
once or twice a year if you'd like to
give me a birthday gift this month
that'd be a great gift send me a tweet
just let me know I'm just at jfm that
you you did it or you can tweet the
minimus at the minimalists we would
really attack so let us know oh yeah
yeah Texas if you don't have Twitter a
lot of you don't I think it's with
twenty four percent of Americans and
well not just America and anywhere you
are in the world we'd really appreciate
a review but yeah just Texas ninety
three seven two oh two four six five
four let us know we're really grateful
for those of you who have decided to
leave us a review well I should also
point out Ryan I shall talk about this
on the maximal episode I've got some
updates for less is now or our next
Netflix documentary and our next book
love people use things I've got some
updates I want to share about both of
those but some of them are sort of
secret updates I only want to share with
the the smaller audience eventually
everyone will know about it so yeah
don't worry don't feel like you're being
left out speaking of following you can
follow the minimalist on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram at the minimalists
come see one of our live podcast shows
the minimalists com slash tour to find a
city near you if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists com comment on this
episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our email list
over at the minimalists comm and you'll
also receive our simple Sunday emails
whenever we send those out and if you
leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for listen
y'all we'll see you next time
every little scene that's just feeding
your green oh I bet that you'd be fine
without
[Music]